good morning everyone welcome to the
morning toast slight delay I [ __ ] my
pants it wasn't a big deal just have to
clean it up your new pants you guys can
we give it up for Claudia okay wearing
clean jeans one day in a row I were in
blue jeans probably I think for the
third time in my life what is the
inspiration behind this look today the
inspiration is like farmer I mean I
watch ACMs last night and I was feeling
inspired by like the whole country farm
vibe that I just decided to you know
grace everyone with some blue jeans it
really is shocking like what I saw you
was the first different
you look different I know taking videos
of you it's a different girl like you
have a different silhouette in blue
jeans it's not a good one and it's not
one now that I'm watching myself on the
stream that I ever want to look like
again so I will be performing a
ceremonial burning of these jeans once
the stream ends you know what like okay
yes dirty jeans my daisen or look better
on the street yeah you look really
really good thank you so much for saying
that I can't look at my phone because
I'm literally hating the blue jeans
they're like reflecting like this ugly
aura onto my face the way that I looked
and it's just it's just tough to start
on my day off like hating yourself the
weather today I hate I hate talking
about the weather but no way really to
get that flash flood warning I let the
asleep with me
and like I was so nervous that he I live
in like literally a building that was
it's made out of paper like when the
wind blows you can hear it inside it
like it's so poorly made that like I
felt like I was sleeping outside last
night like I heard the whistle of the
wind like like it was crazy and I was
like so worried about the oh he was
literally fine slept like a true baby
but like I was worried about him but
like he was totally fine so I was up on
that look worried about the oh when he
was sleeping like maybe right it's
really you were just scared ass mother
he's lame anuncio you guys we have such
a busy show for you today we need to
jump right into it we did like way more
than five stories because we broke them
down like by hotel subsets three story
baby news three stories and we have our
first guests of the toast Connor Dermot
joining us later and we're so excited to
chat with him about what it was like to
perform on The Bachelor
he is even hotter in person or coach
Krystal yeah we have so many shocking
Chucky
get all the scoop but it's out further
ado here are the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take about it out of your morning dose
we're streaming live exclusively on
YouTube today I'm excited to see you
know like what happens yeah to like the
polarization of the viewers you know
yeah Facebook viewers are gonna meet
YouTube viewers for the first time like
you know what's gonna happen I think
it'll be really good for our brand as we
said we're evolving every day as people
as hosts as you know entrepreneurs right
so it'll be exciting to see what being
crazy today like I need you're like yeah
okay this first story is it could be the
only story today because we could talk
about it for an hour but Nikki Bella and
John Cena break up after six years
together they ended their engagement oh
my god it's so crazy because like we
totally called this we were talking
about them last week on the show like
for 10 minutes we had a whole
conversation about them I mean I'm not
shocked by this like she literally had
to force him to propose to her and like
move in if you ever watch that was the
shocking yeah that they got Amy if
you've ever watched literally two
minutes of total divas like you'll know
all you need to know about them as a
couple I'm like I I literally watched
two minutes of total divas where I
thought our no total Bellas I like total
bellows better than total diva me too
because I really don't like a lot of the
girls on total divas
then they there was one episode where
John Cena was picking his like guarantor
you know if he were on like if he were
on life support or something okay so a
guarantor is what you do for an
apartment oh whatever you know like when
you like are on life support emergency
call emergency contact
no no oh who pulls the plug in yes and
he would--he next-of-kin I said yeah he
wouldn't even tell not only was it not
her he wouldn't tell her who it was what
do you think it was I don't know
probably like it was Jerry I feel like
have so many options
totally I would not have been and she
was like an odd number of people like
three or five feel like you guys vote I
would not let Ben be the number one cuz
he would keep me alive forever and like
if I was in
pain and like just let me die in peace
man okay yeah and he would keep you
alive forever and like he would like
pretend like I was a person and like
stuff me and like bring me to lunch with
him no he would definitely get input but
like he wouldn't be the final decision
probably sisters and then I think I
would be like very a very rational
choice you know no but like you say that
now but like me dying would be like the
worst thing that ever happened to you
like so you'd be very emotional I would
but I have an ability to stay rational
even during an emotional time I don't
think that's true I think it's true as
far as all the sisters go
well that's true like honestly I would
not trust Olivia like she can be a
basket case when she's emotional
totally but I can - I snitches pretty
rational first inch okay anyways I'm
really sad for them I believed in that
but it's called power of attorney by the
way right that's what they kept saying
power of attorney I'm really sad like
because I don't know I just feel like
John Cena has so many like a new
projects took like right but that's I
think I think this is what it's about
like in the WWE world they're pretty
much equal like he's the best of the men
she's won the title a bunch of times
she's really famous they have similar
amounts of Instagram followers but like
in the real world his clout is just
growing and growing like he's becoming a
huge film star that I told you that
movie blockers was [ __ ] amazing so
like I just don't think they you know
they're in the same place anymore well
they put on a preview for total Bella's
night on a while I was watching the
Royals and I was like wow this is weird
because I had literally just read that
they broke up and the commercial seemed
poorly time because it's talking about
how they're planning the wedding but
then the end of the commercial it was
talking about how John Cena would be
holding her back from having children
and like he doesn't want to do that and
I feel like maybe she could get him to
propose but it's just so sex I feel like
he'd be an amazing dad I see not from a
previous marriage
does he have kids I don't think so isn't
that the whole thing that he doesn't
want I thought he didn't want cuz like
he had enough kids like a Richard Burke
Monica Geller situation which is why
it's applicable here like so basically
Monica was dating her eye doctor who's
friends with her dad played by Tom
Selleck so hot she loved him so much
you know he just said his could hit off
to college like he doesn't need that
life again he doesn't want to be
changing diapers at the ripe old age of
50 he'll be 75 by him then by the time
the kid graduate from high school only
40 no I know I'm just saying that's the
thought process I don't agree
but that's a thought process of some
some people got it okay I feel really
sad like I just thought like I was every
time I saw them together I'm like good
for you Nikki Bella you know get that
Cena money totally and it's like this
isn't a Channing and Jenna situation
where like I don't they weren't annoying
no and they didn't make me stop leaving
in love and neither do these two I'm
just like sad for both of them because I
was so happy for them yeah and I really
followed them like I used to follow
Nikki Bella nice they're gonna even
though I don't even watch any of the
shows no same but her content wasn't
premium so I had to unfollow I just
can't stand when people's content are in
premium when they have the the platform
to serve premium content to a wide
audience yes like there are some people
out there I know we're thinking of the
same people from the show they have one
show they have one show yeah yeah yeah
and their content isn't premium it's so
bad and then they wonder why like but
they have so many followers yeah but
then they post pictures with like
snapchat filters we say wait show but
honestly it could be any show just
people who just post pictures with their
selfies with snapchat filters like
that's not what Instagram is for I
totally agree that's like get a camera
serve some premium content and just get
with it yeah okay now we have to get
into a Coachella talk because honestly
we've been together for like three hours
so far we have really spoken about it
because I've been dying I have so much
to say I have so much to say the first
thing we're gonna start on we're gonna
start with the good news okay Destiny's
Child reunion and more Beyonce best
moments from her Coachella performance
it was everything okay I only saw a few
clips I'm not going I did not watch the
whole thing
and I didn't really have FOMO from the
whole weekend because like I really
[ __ ] hated going to Coachella it was
like the worst time of my life but I'm
really happy for everyone who was there
like wanted to see Beyonce and they got
what they paid for because like they got
it's expensive
between the plane the ticket the housing
situation the food drink the drinks like
we were hitting up our Apple pay when we
were at Coachella like every 10 minutes
because I was hitting it up yeah so like
I'm glad that everyone who spent a
minimum of two thousand dollars to be
there got what they paid for you know
yeah and I feel like even if she didn't
bring out to us any child it wouldn't be
ya know but the fact that she did that
and was the perfect time to bring them
out cuz no she's not gonna bring them
did she bring him out at the Super Bowl
yes she did she I don't know yeah maybe
she should but it was like she it was
all about her at hotels still but she
was able to make it about them and
everyone was so happy to see it
and it was perfection can I say
something about Beyonce like I bet she's
nice we are some of her harshest critics
I because she faked her pregnancy but
that's why I'm don't worry about it I
don't think she takes her second
pregnancy nothing about Beyonce bothers
me tethered the way other than the way
other people react I know she's good
she's really talented like I like to
watch videos for singing but what I
really like about her is that she's not
threatened like by other people like
Justin Timberlake was so afraid that
been NSYNC reunion would over shine his
Super Bowl performance said he didn't
bring out in sync which is what everyone
wanted but yeah Beyonce understands that
everyone wants to see a reunion and
she's not threatened by Michelle really
I'm see now like she's still above
Michelle Williams so I just like that
every chick always Michelle Williams
yeah yeah boom great a showman are they
both Michelle Williams for sure well we
have a lot of unanswered questions today
I know we need it like we need a scholar
to sit in the back of our studio like
when it comes to entertainment like we
are the scholars like if we don't know
who does okay well I'm gonna say that
her name is Michelle Williams and
Beyonce always brings her out I just
think that's really like she does she
doesn't have to because like Kelly
Rowland is fine like Michelle Williams I
think it's like a cashier or something
so I just think it's really admirable
that she always brings him out and isn't
threatened like by the overshadowing it
of it all but she doesn't always bring
them out she brings him out at the right
time right no no one expects her to
bring it out every time I'm told it's a
big moment Superbowl atella doesn't have
to keep in mind that she was supposed to
perform quick hello last year but then
she was probably cut in so like so many
people bought tickets last year hoping
to see her
oh yeah which like for us was a dream
wait so I but I was gonna say was when
we went to Coachella
I don't think I got my money back
whatsoever I mean I guess like a cool
thing that happened was like Michelle
Williams you were right
Oh Michelle we I'm sorry I guess like I
don't even know Lady Gaga was really
good but look wasn't worth all the
Treach money and sweat I put into
Coachella no cuz she was really the only
performer I wanted to say we left early
to go to that horrible party horrible
horrible except like I feel like at
Coachella okay I didn't get my money's
worth but I definitely you know
important things happened I feel like I
really cemented my friendship with Joe
Jonas and cheese
sophie Turner okay I feel like I made
strides in my friendship with like a lot
of the girl from The Bachelor yeah ma'am
roomie pregame dwith Corinne and like
that was fun we had
best time but as far as the festival one
we didn't get our money's worth but I
don't think we were expecting to you
like that festival it's not me that's
like the parties beforehand that
festival is not made for Jewish people
no there are so many people that we also
need to talk about it can we skip to
Mason Ramsey yeah please because the
Walmart yodeling voice little Hank
Williams with a no-name deejay who
literally is a marketing genius
yeah did you watch the videos of him
perform I did I couldn't [ __ ] hear
him because the crowd was so insane the
crowd it was like they weren't cheering
and they weren't laughing they were just
like yelling evening and it was so like
it was hard why like everything he does
like makes me really sad he's standing
on this big stage she's so tiny with his
microphone link wearing his Sunday best
no and these people are like I was
drugged screaming at him has he washed
that outfit first she hasn't had time
it's not dirty jeans five days in a row
no it's not you know what's so crazy
it's like we've only known Mason Ramsey
for like a week but it feels like I've
known him my whole life
no it's so crazy I was tiny it's like he
just went on his first airplane and you
know he's performing at Coachella do you
know how overwhelming that must be like
he's definitely full in private well cuz
then he performed at the Grand Ole Opry
that night so he had to have flown
private I don't know that there are so
many direct flights from Palm Springs
and it wouldn't have made sense of you
to drive to LA throughout like it just
didn't make sense yeah it's just Grandma
and Grandpa going everywhere they have
to be if they're not I'm I'll be so
upset they should honestly be filming a
documentary right now because I am so
curious about like what the life is like
of someone who shoots too immediate
start them do the internet but what a
million Instagram followers yeah I just
I need to know and typically because I
am of two minds on this like one yeah
Danielle bergoglio mindset and then
you're up the little Hank Williams
mindset just two different ways I don't
go Danielle bergoglio because like
honestly good for her I'm a the backpack
kid mindset we did a little Hank
Williams mindset because on the one hand
it's like we make people overnight
famous and like there's nowhere for him
to go from here like he he completed his
life goal yeah performing everything and
being in a Katy Perry music video when
they put him in college just to keep
fulfilling his you what is he gonna do
in five years from now I don't know but
then on the other hand it's like he is
really talented and he's a really good
singer and he's making like his 60 year
old song famous again yeah like that's
kind of cool no he's amazing he's
amazing but I
like he's getting lumped in I'm just
like with this group of viral people who
become famous for no reason but come on
oh man he's not the backpack kid
wait no I'm sorry this is the Justin
Timberlake selfie who also has over a
million Instagram followers I'm fine
don't worry yes wait I had to tie
something I went to apartments vote for
the weekend and all the kids were like
thottie and like wearing wedges and the
girls were wearing dresses up to their
vaginas and I just thought like it was
amazing i sat the whole time and just
watch the kids not in like a weird had a
feel like way but like it is in a
anthropologist sort of way and I was
enamoured like all their dance moves are
inspired by the internet it's crazy the
power that the Internet has they were
all doing that the fact that could think
they were remember do you see that of
the the kids in the frat house being
like this thing no they were just doing
like they weren't dancing they were
reenacting internet things it was a
mind-blowing research experiment for me
so and I kept looking around I'm like -
any of these thoughts follow me on
Instagram like no one was even looking
at me I'm sorry so it was like a hard
night for me emotionally but like
research they love the backpack kid
thing oh they know and this is the other
thing they know all the words - like
cardi B - like all these Drake songs
that have like such inappropriate and
verbiage and like when we were at Bat
Mitzvah I was like were we saying like
like no I don't think they weren't as
vulgar they weren't as vulgar and yeah I
just think that the scale has has been
changed and gonna push back but that's
really so you know it was honestly we
should go to bar mitzvahs like once a
month and just study oh yeah still the
wall and this is gross but no no no no
but no but they changed the words what -
what there was always like in a clean
version was there whatever the moments
was lit was it open bar
really yeah that's like such a shame
about Bar Mitzvah so uh with that it's
like right before you're like you even
know about alcohol so it's not even like
you're trying to sneak like but kids
these days are [ __ ] insane like I I
didn't the first time I actually got
okay the first time I had a drink I was
probably like 17 but the first time I
actually got drunk was like a week ago
like I just feel like kids these days
are like so mature do you know what I
mean I know they're growing up way too
quickly they're growing up so quickly
they were being so naughty
a youngster this weekend a youngster I
think she's 11 years old
what young sir just like a friend of a
friends okay sir
she was 11 and she was showing me photos
of how she does her makeup cuz she
watches all these makeup tutorials she
wasn't wearing faux glam but she does
like full glam just like Kyle's daughter
Portia yeah he's a makeup artist say
I'll just watch these makeup you join me
on Instagram and they are the next okay
let's get back to Coachella though
because I have so many more selfie and
then this next story that we just wanted
to talk about is first of all the
weekend like hooking up with Chantal
Jefferies he was spotted I saw some
pictures of him with Chantal Jefferies
looking mad clothes maybe a little
smoochy-smoochy then apparently he was
seen kissing Bella Hadid Margot told me
that I'm not that sorry he was there so
it's like I'm like so over the weekend I
don't think he's cute and like what is
with all these like literally gorgeous
girls being obsessed with him I'm making
themselves huge losers just to be with
him okay that's definitely true but like
because like at least the weekends like
talented and like well-respected
she never seems happier yeah no no he's
definitely well-respected he respects
women he respects the hell out of women
for sure but like I just I'm not getting
the allure of it all and like I don't
know why though I had to eat and Selena
Gomez are like maybe they're making
themselves look moronic and look stupid
in the public eye offer like this weenie
no and there's way more than just two
guys in Hollywood like Justin Bieber and
the weekend are two of Weightman and
Chantal Jeffries has hooked up with
Justin Bieber too
so all three of these girls a
competition have Justin Bieber in the
weekend like ever hung out
no I think they have beef because of
Selena but now Salinas single I don't
know I can't keep up like and truly I
don't care
but you did see this picture of I did
weekend Nicki Minaj Shania Twain Naya
tween Timothy Salome Salome and I think
cardi B is in there somewhere too and
French Montana no it was Nicki Minaj and
I just want to say Shania Twain looks
drunk as hell oh my god I didn't even
recognize no I aspire to be the love
like it's a generic I'm like Shania
Twain is like the level of [ __ ] up I
aspire to be this weekend No
she looks crazy good for her why what's
to see good I don't know so we can now
that I'm working Monday through Friday
again I'm living for the weekend working
for the weekend no you don't understand
I'm living five days for two just like
yeah wait what's the song no because
it's my mantra
yeah no literally like I was so tired
this weekend I force myself to go out
and get drunk I'm writing it and I
really regret it Saturday well do you
get fun I woke up with a scratched
cornea did you have fun no well I didn't
okay I'm sorry okay we need to talk
about revolve because as you know we are
[ __ ] enamored with revolve like
basically they sell like $100 skirts and
apparently whatever apparently they make
enough money to supply Coachella in
general put on their best of all they
rented out Merv Griffin estate which we
went to last year but they've decked out
they had a ferris wheel there yeah oh it
was all at Merv Griffin member we were
thinking there was so much land yeah it
was and this is what was so interesting
to me about the whole thing they had
their regular ragtag crew of girls with
two million followers who all wear the
same skirt but they also ventured into
bachelor nation they always have allowed
Lauren and Amanda in because I think a
bachelor mansion Lorna mandar really
premium content always they don't they
don't post iPhone photos no they really
it's their business and they do good
sponsored yes but this year they allowed
in a few more bachelor girls it still
cream of the crop but Daniella bard was
there she was there last year okay
Daniela bard Alexis Rabin Tia was there
but she wasn't with Cristina was there
but she wasn't with her mom she was with
VAM too they both were with them and
jasmine and I just want to say it's like
you could either and you could be a part
of evolve and you could have to one of
two experiences you have a terrible time
you don't drink but you get amazing
photos or you have an amazing time you
drink everything and your photos are
[ __ ] so all the bachelor girls have like
the worst content ever it was like
blurry but like they were drunk and I
was thinking like when we were there
like we were like pretending but like we
wanted to like drink enough on it like
no one was drinking and having fun and
their free drinks
here because I think if we had it we
probably would be judging revolve so
yeah no one's having fun everyone's
taking pictures but we actually had so
much fun in like people have fun and
take pictures but the bachelor girls
like they went how I wouldn't mind like
they didn't care about their photos yeah
like they just went and had fun and they
like big took a blurry picture and they
just put it up
yeah and they all facetune themselves
which I would have done also right I
just think it's interesting just not
batcher
yeah and it was like people weren't like
using like a fine eye which he's
unacceptable but Warren B was separate
from the group she went with McDonald's
and she's getting a lot of backlash for
being like literally weighing 90 pounds
but also doing a McDonald sponsorship
and like I just feel like my goal in
life is for people to be mad at me for
what look I want I want to be so thin
that it's unrealistic I would ever eat
McDonald's do you know any yeah that's
my goal she hates me Donald no I mean
we've been with her everything out there
she eats yeah a lot her and Amanda both
and that's like the dream is to go to
Coachella with McDonald's a house her
house looks like literally my dream yeah
and then Erika Jayne went there too
and we have to talk about Erika Jayne
d2j Moschino she's just like living the
ultimate life yeah and like I just love
a powerful woman in her four days do you
know anyway she's like the talk of the
town in her forties like she's a hot
that never happened her and cardi B are
up there together once pregnant once 40
like the time sorry no really it's all
happening yeah in the words of scheana
Marie Shay it's all happening did you
see cardi B set no oh my god
you're gonna really she was like
obviously so pregnant and just going ham
I [ __ ] love her it looked really
she's also someone who's just like it's
all happening for her and I couldn't be
more happy for her yeah and it's a guy
that she's hanging out Erica Jean it's
like it's also all happening for Julia
Michaels like I'm not as happy for I
find her annoying we're going to talk
about the ACMs in a second but she seems
one line on that silent song to someone
like country music are they so focused
on building up pop stars you know I
think they'd like to crossover it brings
like a cool factor to they seems I think
I guess it does but I like more so in
country fame but no we're the only ones
who like that okay let's talk about the
ACMs Chris Stapleton welcomes twin boys
with wife Morgan and Reba McEntire
announces the birth live it was so cute
he won male vocalist of the year
album of the year he's everything what
are your thoughts I'm obsessed with him
he's so well-respected like even in the
Grammy it's like everyone stands up room
everyone knows who he is I just like I
love him I love his whole aesthetic I
know he definitely smells but like I
don't care I'm so happy for him and his
wife he just loves his wife so much like
I only have good things to say about
Chris Stapleton other than like his
beard definitely grows bacteria but on
that I only have good things like
everything respect you wear dirty cheese
five days in a row but there's no
bacteria I used to race please it was
the best night of my life and like why
okay well I was just I enjoyed it so
much and it's just so rare I'm not used
to watching an award show and not hating
everyone on stage and like I'm I'm just
not over like it was just so good even
with that like I really didn't agree
with a lot of the choices Oh same oh
don't get me started this is the problem
that I like a backroad was the song of
the year I completely agree
I completely agree why will no one just
give that or the fighter he's also
upward this is okay sorry you totally
reminded me the fact that Miranda
Lambert is the most awarded ACM she's
out of any man or when she's the most
ACM Awards is literally a joke the only
song that's good that she has is we were
us and because Keith Urban is on there
first of all over you and the house okay
also um gunpowder and lead yeah but
still but that was like tip that was
when she was still married to Blake
Shelton like she cheated on him by the
way I didn't feel bad for her that very
reliable sources so look I don't feel
bad for her but she's there alone and
like he's there with his new girlfriend
like you ruined him he was like chubby
and like a loser and like you made him
like hot revenge body and now he's with
Gwen Stefani's like look what you did
when when Stefani was mouthing the
lyrics to Blake Shelton song like I was
dying I'm telling it was the best night
ever
here what was your favorite performance
um Carrie Underwood oh my god okay we
have to talk about is so much cheaper so
I love that song give me to her album is
about Carrie Underwood
and her music so her last album was
storyteller and it was obviously all
songs that are based on other people's
experiences yeah because that song about
Jenny Jenny in the church and she
murders her husband yeah she really
detached herself from her music which is
like nice because think he just enjoyed
that song about her dad actually but now
that I think about it and so now this
new song but now that I think about it
how out of touch
maybe me Jenny and the church is is
about Carrie Underwood all his money
could never say Jenny I love that song
but the lyrics are so weird they have a
same gelee yeah I agree
also like two black Cadillacs like she
isn't a widow who shot her no but this
is thing she has a lot of songs about
like hating her husband okay and then
she also mysteriously fell flat it fell
down a flight of stairs
no but that's my point my point is is
that she really detaches herself from
her songs that to the point where this
song you would think like the first time
you hear like oh my god what's going on
with Carrie Underwood but a lot of her
songs aren't about her but I feel I do
feel like this one is but it's nice that
she's kind of set that boundary no she
was singing her heart out and I was like
here for it but then when she won the
next award like and she almost died I
was like that was not cool in ocm so you
know that they set that up that way so
they could catch her off guard no I know
and like honestly like I don't think
she's okay
no she's not like emotionally I wonder I
wonder what happened this was like the
big reveal yeah I know Jimmy bunts no
not even just finds like I don't mean
she's going through something a lot of
different stuff I just said she's going
through something she did an amazing job
last night and she looks beautiful she
is beautiful well there was this big
reveal of her face like her face looks
red she just looks like she got lip
fillers but maybe that's what she wants
you to think I don't know no but me like
herpes definitely looks a little
different but it doesn't look like she
got injured different it just looks like
she got some fillers yeah um okay why
don't you wanna ask me who my favorite
performer was your favorite bebe Rexha
and Florida Georgia line really okay so
like I always say mean things about bebe
Rexha and I'm here to say that I was
wrong yes I do know when she was talking
about her mom
Oh actually yeah yeah yeah but I've
always said she's not really like a
musician or like a lyricist like she was
so good and this is the thing like when
you watch the Grammys are you watch like
another fake what is like another
People's Choice Award I heart yeah Mike
nobody can sing in pop it's like who's
gonna be it's always like in pop like
who's gonna be good you know because
everyone stinks like they sound good on
there like iTunes but in real life like
it's like not that good so with the
Country Music Awards like the total I
mean sorry not Country Music Academy of
Country Music it's the total opposite
it's like everyone sings amazing
everyone plays them like no one's faking
it
yeah so then when they bring in my
crossover people I'm like oh they're
gonna stink it up but bebe Rexha was so
good she really helped around I [ __ ]
love Florida Georgia line like they're
cool factor is astronomical and I just
love that song that is truly the best
song I love them I love their look like
a took me a while to come around so I
think we're looking like good last night
yeah it took a while but it also took
them a while like they used to dress
weird but in ads when they have that
song cruise yeah and that the one guy
who was wearing all white like we used
to have the same hairstyle well there's
just like straight shoulders and with
more Farquaad senators there is a trend
there's a trend in country music for
like duo's or trios to have like one
person who doesn't sing so in Florida
Georgia line the guy in the white on the
Left doesn't sing he harmonizes a little
any plays guitar any dan + Shay Dan
doesn't sing
Jackie fix your mic I don't know which
one's Dan Richmond Shay I don't know ok
so the little short chubby one who has
the amazing voice is Shay okay and the
one with like the very soft-spoken voice
boo - plays guitar really well is Dan I
think yeah yeah well we saw them at see
twitch and I didn't notice that one with
it was the first thing I noticed you mad
at a the older sister or the sisters no
the older one only sings and in Lady
Antebellum the guy on the right doesn't
say I feel like then in those cases
especially with Lady Antebellum like the
person who doesn't sing is always like
the most musically and kind likely Jonas
Brothers
can sing but he like played all the
instruments and definitely wrote the
songs no I think Nick world songs no I
just think they included Kevin like just
to be nice cuz like their dad made that
yeah okay anything else when the CMAs
Ballerini did amazing chilled - so
pretty
marinara Morris that that time was so
cool and honestly she's just the coolest
girl alive no goals and
I don't that's not my favorite song of
hers but she need me really like some
really good song but it's a bigger song
that's why they sing it okay me single
but it's also Mandalay Bay and deer hate
was robbed oh how could you miss at a
country music event of the year and not
give it to deer hey well that's why they
gave it to Jason Aldean cuz he's hardly
Entertainer of the Year like he's
Entertainer of the Year Lee over like
Luke Bryan Chris Stapleton Jackie he is
not funny yet like he had a year no I'm
telling you that's why they gave it to
ya but they should have been addicted to
your hate that's one that's my boy they
should have given it to hear hey because
they were obviously giving out like pity
awards and deer hate should have gotten
it no no I'm sorry Jesus captured like
the essence of how a room was feeling I
expected so much more from Jason Aldean
and his speech and he really let me down
and I just don't like it honestly I was
in the shower and he and I watched royal
and he just walks around with his wife
like pretending they're all nice and
supple like please that was an affair if
I've ever seen one yeah but now that
they've made it nice no I agree I love
when people like make raunchy things
nice yeah like I never forget
no there was like a sort of Real
Housewives of Dallas yeah like how
Carrie and her husband like they might
have started but they made it nice but
then and then you have to like be nice
about it yeah because they made a nice
you couldn't help how you meet someone
or how you fall in love wait I have so
many more things it was literally the
best night of my life
Reba and Kelly Clarkson were giving me a
me and are they still related no because
we got divorced that was confused yeah
also Kelly Clarkson so skinny did you
say yes I saw she looked amazing I'm
still happy for her you know I love her
you know she's my dream guest I know but
I'm so confused like is she country or
is she pop she's both get you a girl who
can do both she rides into her own lane
and honestly on her new album there's
like a little bit of gospel to she
didn't like make me crazy like the one
before it made me like feel all the
feels piece by piece dance me this song
this one's like not as amazing but it's
pretty good but every time she puts out
a song as a single I like it more and
then when there's arena cuz I like it
even more so the whole album like didn't
move me ya know it was called even
though there's a song called movie I I
keep watching myself in these jeans I'm
like I really like that I'm burning them
stop it has to be somewhere where I'm I
have a totally where them I'm never
gonna be photographed or like take it
like it's these are horrible so like
maybe a meeting I like the movies you
would wear jeans to them nah we're okay
pants exclusively more baby news John
Stamos and his wife Caitlin make house
welcome their first child you know he's
a normal name I remember reporting the
story when they were pregnant you know
and yet we've really come full circle so
much time has passed now we've had the
baby happy for them cool can we get to
the next story you know when people have
babies like there's literally nothing to
say like Congrats Congrats crap your
life is over
stop okay the sex week really confuses
me because Eva from Real Housewives of
Atlanta and her fiance Michael sterling
welcomed their first child not her first
child but their first child the other
however wait show me her picture Eva
she's from Atlanta and she was on
America's Next Top Model oh yeah
however last night I'm Real Housewives
of Atlanta she came on she was having
contractions ten minutes apart and then
she was going to the hospital I thought
she was giving birth that was a few
weeks ago so well
yeah that sounds you didn't lay but it's
probably not contractions it's like
gasps she said she was having
contractions ten minutes apart after she
was getting up she was going in the
hospital like to give birth oh it's a
story old no it's she gave birth on
Friday isn't that confusing
yeah who's just weird that they
announced it the same day like well
congrats what's the baby's name um
the bundle of joy noting their baby
Michael Todd sterling jr. I really just
want to go back I don't feel like I
spoke enough [ __ ] about Miranda Lambert
it's really pissing me off I really
don't like her and they put it on my
Instagram story and I put like a lot of
[ __ ] on my Instagram story and like most
the time people agree with me like I got
terrible backlash for what I said about
Marine Lab Rats random baguette Marco
yeah Betty Mellencamp yeah those people
you can't talk [ __ ] about but I will
continue to talk [ __ ] about Miranda
Lambert she bothers me so much I can't
believe she's the most like awarded
woman or man she stinks well just
confuses me because we love country
music
love love love especially female country
like that like borders on pop and yeah
it's like we should love Miranda Lambert
I wonder why we never got into her music
oh I know why cuz it's terrible stop no
it is actually I don't know I like her I
don't know she's literally the worst and
like I'm we're going to see him I'm like
choking today um last night really
inspired me to like make my plans for
CMA fest so like now we're found finding
like tickets and lodging and I'm so
excited
literally everyone in the world is
performing except Kacey Musgraves where
the hell was Kacey Musgraves last night
I don't know it's like she's not part of
the Academy
he's not and by the way when Raylan when
Carly parts when one of them was on our
show they were telling us that like they
have this girl group cassadee Pope
Danielle Bradbery they're like all
really good friends Kaleigh dickerson
but Casey's like not a girl's girl and
she's like not in it even though they
all posted about Casey's album they like
all supported her they all do that for
each other it is so nice it also lets me
know what up-and-coming female yeah
country starts have his new song I like
she's gonna be at stagecoach which is
the only one we can't go to and I'm like
so miserable about it but like it's
really upsetting me that she's going on
tour with Harry Styles cause like as
much as I would love to see them
together like last time I went to see
Casey my my kids Muskies my tickets were
$90 and I was like front-row it was
amazing I love undiscovered artists
ticket prices are gonna be out of
control and it's just not right because
imagine Kacey Musgraves playing a
concert in New York City like not that
many people would go no I know we could
have the cream of that's what I deliver
I was but you didn't mention how to take
it prices there's just I really cuz I
said I got $90 tickets and I was in the
front row you didn't mention ticket
price I actually mentioned a specific
ticket price but she's not everyone in
the world is gonna be up to Ma Fest I
looked at the lineup yesterday like I
say someone's a male type in there um
right then yes um madam iris oh wait
maybe not maybe actually whatever every
no I love who Chris not lean young yes
who sings when I think man I think I
love him me too and he has the voice of
an oven he's hot he is hot like that hot
I love him when he was singing I was
like damn I would suffocate underneath
him but I would like it where was Brett
Eldredge last night my thoughts exactly
wasn't nominated for diddly-squat
I think his album came out a long time
how was it not nominated it's literally
the greatest album of all time anyways
everyone is sleeping on Lauren Alaina
and you've oh my god I've been taking a
[ __ ] now over a year
I just got Katie for her album it was
the album of the year jackie has
literally been shoving Lauren Alaina
down my throat like every single song is
either like a banger or just so
introspective and just makes you think
her song 3 it's it's similar to um Jenny
in the church man ok it comes full
circle
oh yeah didn't you go home can you lay
on your bed yes
like when he's sleepy put in your
earphones and just play the album yeah
no I'm going to cuz last night I love
that song what if and King Brown is hot
look I can't
he's nicly ambiguous but like I don't
care he's so hot he's so hot but she
totally out saying him well so that's
the thing he came on and then Shannon
was she out saying this song it's not a
big enough song for her yes so she came
out and I was like damn mortally they
came get it then she's saying she got
two performances like she was really and
then Margo's like oh look at her
Instagram there's such a cute video of
her hysterically crying when Reba told
her she wasn't atm
so then I started out with her after
that and then I tagged her in my
Instagram story and I guess I had never
seen it but she's messaged me a month
ago actually been sleeping on her and I
was taking a cold hard nap and it's
unacceptable except table and you better
wake up also she is a spokesperson for
Atkins which is [ __ ] goals I love
country music
all the women look normal it's like so
nice no and their friend and they all
just like exude confidence no matter
what they look like um oh my god I got
another emergency flash blood 2:15 I
think you got it didn't go off I was
actually thinking about absolutely
shocking annoying and so annoying I had
one more thing to say about the ACMs but
I just can't remember
oh so interesting how American Idol is
really represented in country music
Scotty McCreery borin Elena Manila
Clarkson Carrie Underwood key all and
now Luke Bryan all Keith Urban no no all
let me [ __ ] say it I can't speak Oh
like vocal singing shows are represented
because Danielle Bradbery Raylan and
cassadee Pope are also all from the boys
true country just like they love
talented people yeah it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter where you pass talent
Jake it does another here parrots are it
doesn't matter here will just take you
for you talent okay this last story
fifth and final we're gonna have it
quick before we bring on Connor Gwyneth
Paltrow and Brad Falchuk celebrate
engagement a star-studded party this
weekend okay as you guys know I'm
absolutely in love with um
Gwyneth Paltrow and I'm only upset that
like she's getting engaged because that
means she's not gonna marry me but I got
to spend the weekend with her in Mexico
and with Brad he's such a like a caring
like guy and he's just he's up he's like
obviously hot but then like his mind is
hot too do you know any me I mean I know
that because
Glee wrote scream queens and Glee two of
which are just an unstoppable combo I
just absolutely loved one of Paltrow
want good things for only one coupe to
be successful I never thought I would
say that I just want her to be happy I
want her kids to be happy I just
absolutely love her same what cuz you do
because you made me think positive
notion I mean I mean so much nicer to
like her than to dislike her because she
really has it all going on but I
obviously loved her when she was um she
said so many iconic roles like the
substitute teacher in Glee shallow how
so like she's obviously like oh that
movie about the airplane flight
attendant the best movie of all time and
also like Shakespeare I never saw Emma I
never saw that one me neither okay she's
just she's a girl who could do it all so
she's like a 90s icon which is just like
the dream Oh Country Strong okay I love
that she sings you know yeah okay so we
are going to take a quick break we're
gonna be back with our first guest
Connor if you guys have questions for
Connor we're we're live on YouTube so
make sure to leave a comment we'll be
back in a jiffy we'll see you then
you
okay we are back with Connor German hi
Connor your thank you for joining us are
you excited to be here
I am are you where you from and tell us
about yourself oh man let's see I come
from a big family diverse family parents
of all both my parents have been married
three times at this point on their third
marriage is successful at this point oh
yeah we love a happy ending a lot of
siblings a couple stepbrothers multiple
half-brothers half-sister and then we
took in a couple kids so I grew up with
a really diverse family and a lot of
culture that's awesome yeah with that
played sports did theater when you were
how old when I've been singing since I
was a little kid me too my mom says I
really have not well I still have to do
it yeah
maybe later okay me too no my mother is
a singer taught me about music when I
was really young that my band that I was
in called jam with Phil which is like a
little jamming group we opened for
Macklemore and Ryan Lewis cool that's so
cool yeah yeah two weeks and you guys
probably recognized Conor because you
were on the episode of The Bachelor you
performed on The Bachelor which is such
a prestigious gig first of all you
performed on the date with Arie and
crystal which we'll talk about in a
second are you familiar at all with like
the show the dynamics like who crystal
was to an extent that she wasn't anyone
at that dress she was still like wanting
to be a normal person do you get to meet
them behind the scenes how did it go did
you see any of the red flags I did not
she was really sweet but was not like
she didn't open up Ari was
well yeah because he's a controversial
character these days ari I think right
yeah how do you feel about him now did
you watch the show before he went on I
watched one season with my mother when I
was you know it was so different back
then
it really was I don't know much about it
now I think obviously with social media
in the way everything's developed it's
naturally gonna just take a new form as
yeah yeah exactly so how did you how did
that come to be what was the process
like today reach out to you my manager I
think had of contact with ABC and
reached out to them like years ago about
like oh if you ever have anything that
comes up with us know we have this
artist does this style of music and at
some point they reached out so now
you're you're part of a long line of
artists who have been on The Bachelor
barracks and it always like catacombs
people at so dan + Shay were on and they
literally became famous the next day
like they were totally blown up then
Russell Dickerson was on he was a close
personal friend Chris Lane was oh yeah
and then I heard that afterwards he was
like messaging some of the girls oh yeah
that's great
love know his I figure I just didn't
want to pry you know yeah now that was
another question we got for you how old
are you 25 same she's engaged know what
how would you describe like your genre
of music my music is pop soul pop so yes
so for me is always something that I've
craved in anything that I consume this
more it's like entertainment in the arts
somebody puts their soul into something
oh I usually eat it up it's not
something I love
do you like so personally alright nobody
was technically the south like it it's a
North Carolina but ya grew up eating
soul food yeah pop so it's it's I wanted
to have you know current elements and
themes of music so that it's more
relatable to the masses ultimate goal
it's obviously reach as many people with
it as possible but for me it always
comes from either something personal or
something that I can connect to with
other people in their lives and yeah who
are like artists who look up to you give
me like a Gavin DeGraw bad oh is that an
insult no it's not I don't know
hey actually there's a old cover of me
singing belief by cat by Gavin DeGraw
and I love the song chariot he's
actually he's got a lot of good they
actually he's a really he's a beautiful
Rider
yes everything you know and you remind
me of who ryan OneRepublic Ryan Tedder
Wow I've never gotten either of those a
hundred percent all of the time get
Justin Timberlake Oh totally that's
that's the only way that's right it's a
it I gathered that from listening and he
never once insane to perform at them
yeah afraid of being overshadowed which
i don't well we were at the Super Bowl
yeah there's nothing to say no was it
yesterday oh this past performance yeah
yeah that's it stuff his performance at
the Music Awards the Grammys what was it
like five years ago we had like that 25
minute long it was MTV video Vanguard
Award oh yeah yeah you cannot like it
couldn't top that at that point that was
incredible
and and I think I've seen him live i
watch this 20/20 tour he's an amazing
performer that show was really it was
underwhelming so where can everyone
learn more about you follow you on
social media find your music so social
media every handle across the board is
at Conner Dermot and yep d ue RMIT co NN
o R is the first name flip those around
um yeah and then new music coming out
I'm working on a lot of new stuff we
just signed some with a small record
label known strangers and we just signed
a distribution deal with Empire Records
so we are getting ready to release have
a new single coming out that we're
having a music video for that's actually
in virtual reality space which was a ton
of fun we filmed that with every shot it
with like I got in the the soup yeah
with all the stuff when I was dancing
and moving stuff and so I now I have a
character
in this virtual reality space and then
it's okay it's yep well thank you for
being here thank you so much you guys
for tuning and make sure you're
following the morning toast on Facebook
Instagram YouTube and in the podcast app
that way you get a notification of every
time a Goliath which is Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time I'm
Claudia asteroid girls their job I'm
Jackie ah hey Jackie Oh problems we'll
see you tomorrow have a great day good
bad Minnie
you